[Music]
to talk to you about your movie the
world's end it's about your character
initiates this this pub crawl yeah that
he wants to go on this epic pub crawl
twelve pubs twelve pubs and I'm curious
have you ever partaken in a pub crawl I
never did it I never did a pub crawl mm
no I I was more of a mind to go
somewhere and stay there what's the
point walking yeah I never got those
drinking it gets harder and harder
anyway so I would always camp out but
there is this thing we have in the UK
mainly sort of guys on a bachelor party
nurses specific groups will do it groups
of nurses oh yeah then they go back to
work
yes that's terrific but you know it's
this thing of you have one pint and you
move to the next pub you have another
pint and you go on as long until you die
you went on one one no I
yeah we did I I went on Nick Frost who's
in the film with me I went on the last
one I went on with was on it was my stag
do my wishes was a bachelor party we
caught a stag do stag do stag do you say
so you guys have such kooky names for
things and I it's maybe language what
you're always like it'll have a chimney
blanket you know you know it's a cookie
its its cordis that we could have stag
night but then yeah when you have a
party is about you ever bit of a do yeah
so that becomes a stag do sure 91 was in
Belgium it was a we went we went to
Brussels we went out in search of a
gentleman's bar we figured you know we
should do that we should go to a strip
club basically we were guys that we
should do it it's just a nicer way to
call it yeah gentlemen a gentleman's
established yes yeah those places are
loaded with gentlemen yeah
we try we couldn't find one eventually
we found one in some back alley and it
just wasn't very nice there were a lot
of the people there were bruised there
was bruised nude and it was a beautiful
sort of Russian dancer on the stage and
she was kind of it with yeah this is it
this is where we're supposed to be
unless you turn someone obviously need
her in the leg that's today was very
depressing and we felt chased and we
left and we went to a bar which was
called the [ __ ] which was a famous but
it's true it's been roost you're sure it
was a bar it was a bar also a
gentlemen's club the irony was is that
we'd spent all night looking for boobs
and wound up in the car yes yes it often
happened I've heard this throughout the
years acting drunk is one of the hardest
things to do then yeah but people tend
to overdo it or you get very wrong I
think yeah so that you had to for this
role you had to be very precise in your
area drunk acting we had 12 stages of
drunkenness basically we did this in
rehearsals we came up with 12 stages of
drunkenness this is offset in the movie
because we get into a lot of fights in
the pubs right and this course is what's
called the adrenaline deficit you know
when you get into a bar fight right you
betcha and you have and that takes a
couple of points off your drunk
awareness so if we're a because of
adrenaline you're become more aware take
the edge off but basically we had 12 the
12 stages of drunkness which we could
drop into any one time because you know
if we're in the first pub you're not
very drunk to be honest the first six is
much of a muchness you can't really tell
you can cover it up right six random at
seven you get the slow I blink comes in
that's that it's very subtle
back back pint nine you get your neck
falls out with your head so your head
just starts problem
you're really good at that
so if I just if I just called one out
you could do it yeah you're that good
give me one for four this is that this
is easy look I'm drunk enough to cover
it up so you're not gonna see anything
go above six go up high eight eight
that's just before the neck so that's
just like that there are two things ten
you go you start to lose your short-term
memory yeah so every 30 seconds
you remember how drunk you are yeah you
do this by the time by the time you get
to 12 you are in total denial about you
are convinced that you're sober
convinced but you are drunker than
you've ever been
so you just dismiss everything and you
do this
[Music]
[Applause]